here in Los Angeles there's just been a
lot of excitement over LeBron James
coming here and they can't believe why
he's here or how he came here but we
we've learned on the Rich Eisen show
LeBron was chased out of town by Jarvis
Landry
I think Jarvis Landry APRI came too
close and and I think he told the Bron
this town's not big enough for the two
of us LeBron is now here in Los Angeles
and Cleveland Browns wide receiver
Jarvis Landry here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Jarvis you there George
are you doing I'm fine is that a true
story did you tell the Brahmas town's
not big enough for the two of us and
that's why he's here in Los Angeles no
I'll tell the king that man okay I don't
think you saw the king yet because I
know you I know the Browns are brash I
know you're bringing a certain brashness
to Cleveland but not that brash is what
you're saying yeah how physical I guess
not how physical can this offense be
Jarvis no I think our division demands
it you know I think you know when you
play teams like the Steelers and
Baltimore and Cincinnati you know that
type of football you know you have to be
able to run a football you got to be
tough and those games are probably the
most physical and you'll get out the
whole year you know you play those guys
twice a year so you know I think the
demand for us is uh it's definitely
there and I you know I know cuz she
wouldn't you guys would get us ready to
be ready so cuz I mean that's the first
thing I thought of when you join the
team to be honest with you Jarvis is I
mean you've got over already guarded
Dave and Joe ku who came in studio
before he was drafted I mean that guy's
like a redwood tree he's built and then
Josh Gordon and now you I you know you
better pack a lunch if you're taking on
the Cleveland Browns this fall and the
first team that you got out of the box
is Pittsburgh I'm wondering if you're
already circling that one Jarvis that
that's where you could start serving
notice on everybody that this is a
winless team is no longer gonna be a
trifle
yeah you know I don't think I don't
think you know everything's a
coincidence you know I think that uh
being in the situation that Cleveland
has been in in the stigma that's been
over the Browns organization for so long
you know and to finally start putting
pieces together you know myself tie
right you know defensively as well and
to have opportunity on the first game to
go you know measure ourselves against a
team that's a playoff continue to the
Super Bowl continue team every year in
our division it's definitely gonna be
you know example for our season Jarvis
Landry Browns wide receiver here on the
Rich Eisen show and how his Tyrod Taylor
looked so far Jarvis
amazing amazing and just you know his
leadership is on apathy and he's he's
ready man he's the starting quarterback
in you know I'm sure that obviously had
decision is to hew and you know an
offensive staff and stuff like that but
I'm sure that they have been highly
impressed with what he's done to OTAs
and then the return kit minicamp though
ya know I know obviously that decision
goes further up the chain but in terms
of what Tyrod can do with this offense
compared to the first overall selection
in Baker Mayfield I mean how is that
even a competition in in training camp
you know what I think you know I think
both guys are highly competitive you
know I know I know just having to talk
to bake and you know I know he wants to
play you know but obviously you know
just talking to him to I understand that
you know he see there's opportunities
for him to grow as a physician you know
a guy like Tyra who's been to the Super
Bowl
who's took a buffalo team that hasn't
mentioned a playoff to the playoffs you
know he can learn a lot from Colorado
same time so you know I think is the
competition yeah but I think too at the
same time you know both guys are
definitely qualified for the job it's
funny every time I hear from Earvin
anytime there's a conversation Michael
Irvin who I get to work with all the
time
you know who talked who loves physical
wide receivers and you're one of them
you know that anytime there's a
conversation about a quarterback
competition that he laughs that that
there's always a stigma to that that
people think that quarterbacks shouldn't
have to compete for their jobs that just
get it handed to them
Jarvis I mean do you think that
quarterbacks competition at quarterback
is a is something that is good when it
comes down to it man I think in any
sport you know competition is healthy
you know and I think that you need that
in every position on your team you know
it's how God you push to get better so
no matter what the position I don't care
the kicker me so um you know you bring
another the kicker in you know I think
he's gotta feel that pressure that you
know he's potentially coming to take his
job so you know it's gonna make it work
harder gonna make him stay longer
whatever you got to do to make sure you
secure his job I think you know it's
healthy to have competition in all
positions okay and in terms of
competition with you and Odell Beckham
going back to the day that you do Odell
we saw him go yard in batting practice
for in Yankee Stadium just the other day
Jarvis I mean if you and Odell got in a
batting cage would you would you fare
better what would you say if you we put
you in a batting cage Widow don't know
what we might have to line that up you
might have to line that up a seat and
see how it goes
baseball especially my first court so a
big site what do you mean it was your
first sport talk to me about this
it's literally the first sport I ever
played the first and father I ever touch
was a baseball I'm playing though so I
was pretty much going to college so
it'll be interesting
it'll be interesting okay when you say
interesting you mean better than Odell
is that what you're saying I'm saying it
landed okay all right you know the
Indians the Indians at batting practice
81 times a year or two in Cleveland so
okay let me let me so what was your game
did you have a power game when you play
baseball you know I got on base if I
need to get on base if I need to you
know SEC slide whatever hit the ball on
the ground whatever it was you know just
find a way to make a play so
many tools out of five did you have how
many tools out of the five did you have
when you play baseball
we were five-tool player for what do you
got that's for damn sure
okay so when it all comes down to it
Jarvis the goals for the Cleveland
Browns this year are what to win tell
you different you know I can't you know
make up something like it's so wet okay
now tell me before I let you go about
TCL America's fastest growing TV brand
is affording you affording us to have
you on the show today
Jarvis pretty much see Sierra you know
as you said they're the fastest growing
television brain you know they actually
doing a campaign right now on national
cut to court cut the cord day you know
they're giving away a hundred and three
TVs you know you can still get all the
games all the sports channels you know
everything cut the cord is pretty much
you know turning away from cable you
know and once you pay a hundred three
dollars a month you know I think that's
the reason behind a three TVs get in the
way you know and I've been with them you
know like I said for couple years so
just from college how the screen plays
everything that you represent man is
really high quality
okay Jarvis and so people can on a TCL
television watch you on Hard Knocks this
summer correct okay you can be a star on
that one are you gonna are you gonna
look are you gonna shower way from the
cameras what do you got for me what type
of hard knocks person am I gonna see how
to Jarvis Landry listen on playing
background music I don't be in the
background here in the background we
have a okay so you'll be up front
biggest HBO star since Game of Thrones
is what you're saying Jarvis Landry yeah
okay well you say you're gonna be the
king of the north
the AFC North I'm not why not okay
Jarvis no you caught me I did I did I
did and I appreciate you taking the time
let us know when you're out here in Los
Angeles I'd love to have you here in
person you got it at God underscore Sun
eighty that's Jarvis Landry of the
Cleveland Browns the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience